The academy is a huge enterprise in,
in the United States there are 6,500
institutions that do higher education.
There are public and private.
There are community colleges to research
universities.
They're there,
they're large,
they're small,
they're urban,
they're rural,
so the the university and college and
Community College,
the Higher Education Complex in the
United States is unbelievably diverse
and by the way that's one of its great
strengths is because it is
decentralized,
it,
it's.
It's highly competitive on one hand,
highly cooperative on the other and it's
hard to think of any question to which
there's a single answer for the entire
complex realism of higher education that
that having been said,
if I were to try to focus on one issue
that that loomed large across the entire
spectrum of the 6,500 schools that are
operating in higher education.
I would say that there is at this moment
in this country which which has without
question a higher education system.
That is the envy of the world.
There is in process a tectonic change in
the way our society views higher
education and it is not for the good.
There is bias and law judge,
a subliminal devaluation of higher
education even as we overtly as a
society say how important it is,
so we're disinvesting in it.
We're beginning to treat it more as a
private good.
Then as a public good,
and and this in the long term is is
quite a challenge to the higher
education establishment,
but I went to school here in New York
state.
There was a New York state regents
scholarship that you could win as a,
as a competitive prize that paid for
room board and tuition for you to go to
a private school and today the aid
that's given by New York state is,
is a small fraction of the cost of
attending anything but a public school.
So it's a small fraction of paying the
cost of attendance at one of the elite
private colleges or universities of New
York state.
Now,
part of that is because what we expect
from higher education has has,
has gone up that that the cost of a
private education has gone up greatly,
but,
but that's because the quality of what's
being provided has gone up greatly.
That the diversity of courses,
the,
the ratio of faculty to students that we
as a society have have not continued the
willingness we showed after World War
Two to invest heavily in that higher
education,
whether it be in the research side or in
making it available to students and,
and that in the long term is a major
mistake by public policy makers.